it's really funny when you think about
it Matt Damon and Ben Affleck then Matt
Damon and Ben Affleck now you
exponentially kick more ass as you get
older that's that's law
Jason Bauer so Jason Bourne is the
fourth Jason Bourne movie in the Bourne
saga although there was that Jeremy
Renner Bourne movie that people were
like oh can you bring back Matt Damon so
they did and then Jason Bourne Jason
Bourne ultimately it does what Jason
Bourne does Jason Barnes on the run is
kicking ass he's trying to find answers
a surveillance tech roomful of people
are tracking him and trying to chase him
down enemy the state style so is enemy
of the state meets James Bond meets
Manchurian Candidate Jason Bourne in a
nutshell and these movies are reliably
entertaining and this is entertaining
first of all Matt Damon has not lost it
he was in fact barred fought as so
stupid I was stuck between born for this
and born to be wild either of which
would result in me punching myself in
the deck after I turned this video up
another dude still kicking ass it does
have that Jason Bourne shaky-cam that
we're all now accustomed to but it's
fine and fine is what I described this
movie as it's entertaining it's fine
problem is we've seen it all before in
many movies including but not limited to
the Bourne movies that have come before
this I kind of compare the Bourne movies
to the side scroller Castlevania games
that came after Castlevania Symphony of
the Night they're all reliably good and
they're all the same thing with a
different skin those are the Bourne
movies in a nutshell and Jason Bourne is
no exception this movie does have a cool
rival assassin that's going up against
Jason Bourne and they have a grudge
against each other so you have that
nemesis dynamic it's not just an old guy
in a suit I mean you do have an old guy
in a suit Tommy Lee Jones is like the
old guy in a suit but you have Johnny
assassin grudge against Jason Bourne
going after Jason Bourne also and that
that added something to the movie and
the last chase sequence in this movie is
by far the thing I'm going to remember
from Jason Barnes as the movie was
entertaining be it a lot of stuff we've
seen before but that last chase sequence
was pretty [ __ ] cool granted it does
come at the end of the movie you would
hope that thing that's really going to
stick with you comes throughout the
movie but I can't say that I can say
Jason Bourne is entertaining it's
reliably entertaining it's very familiar
for all the other Jason Bourne movies
that have come before this Jason Bourne
need to be made no but it was me
and I will say Jason Bourne is a
goodtime no alcohol required right guys
so Jason Bourne have you seen it what
did you think about it or what's your
favorite Bourne movie of any of them
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more